Speaker 1: Speaking of violence, we haven't
done this for a while and and I think it's
important to do it again.
Did you know that there were 10 mass shootings
this past weekend, just this past weekend
that finished a couple of days ago?
The Gun Violence Archive tracks mass shootings.
And on June 4th, 5th and 6th, there were 10
individual shooting incidents in which a minimum
of four victims were shot, either injured
or killed, not including any shooter who may
have also been injured or killed during the
incident.
This is 10 incidents where at least four people
were killed and or injured.
And consider for a second by this definition
of mass shooting where you need at least four
injuries or deaths.
There were a whole bunch of other incidents
with two or three people being injured and
killed when the baseline is set at four injured
and killed.
We had 10 such incidents this past weekend
and it barely made news.
It is just another normal weekend in the United
States of America.
Some examples.
In Portland, Oregon, four were killed and
one were injured at a home in Indianapolis,
Indiana.
Two were killed and two were injured, all
in the parking lot of a Boston market restaurant
in North Carolina.
Four people were shot and injured at a party
at a trailer park.
And I could go through and give you all of
the various stories.
But you can imagine how all of these or many
of these went down.
But 10 mass shootings this weekend and it
barely makes news because it has become background
noise.
That's the tragic reality of the situation,
the loss of life, the injury.
That's one tragedy.
The other tragedy is that this stuff barely
even makes the news anymore.
Another weekend, another 10 mass shootings,
and the number is probably more like 25 if
you include those where two or three people
were injured as well.
Also, it's embarrassing.
It's not just tragic.
It's embarrassing.
The world looks at us clearly.
We have the resources for dealing with this.
It's not a money issue.
We have no shortage of ideas for how to deal
with it, even, you know, without touching
the Second Amendment, which we have a Second
Amendment, OK, without even going close to
infringing on the Second Amendment, we have
so many ideas for things that should be done.
Look at what happened on vaccines once we
got competent leadership in power in January.
We clearly can do things.
We clearly can manage big projects.
There's no it's not an impossibility.
And yet there is simply no political will
to deal with this.
And it's a global embarrassment, truly.
And, you know, even if you don't care about
gun violence per say, like maybe you don't,
do you realize how this makes us look to our
adversaries and the ideas that this gives
our adversaries?
They see another weekend, another ten mass
shootings.
What the hell is wrong with these Americans
if the they are saying if the U.S. population
has been propagandized enough that they won't
do anything on guns if they can't even pass
one hundred percent universal background checks
when when Democrats control the House, Senate,
White House and right after the Sandy Hook
shooting.
If they can't do that, clearly these are very
manipulatable people.
This is one of those situations where the
world sees the insanity of this.
Is this not yet affecting the right people?
And that's why nothing is being done.
Is the.
Combination of the gun profit lobby, because
that's what they are and the gun nuts, is
that combination too powerful to allow anything
to be done?
My issue isn't even with the firearms necessarily,
but it's with American gun culture, lack of
screening, lack of enforcement of laws, lack
of of ongoing training, insurance policies
if you own guns, lack of access to mental
health treatment, the political movement that
fetishizes guns.
Yeah, OK, the guns are a problem.
But what I mean is it doesn't have to be a
problem of guns necessarily.
And I'm being careful with the wording here.
In our case, it is a problem of guns, but
also of all of those other things that I mentioned.
And the world sees it.
And it's humiliating.
It's tragic.
It's embarrassing.
And there is no I mean, I wish I had any optimism.
I have no optimism, you know, OK, Biden announced
some stuff.
They're going to be he is directing the creation
of certain groups to look at, OK, it was an
effort, but most of that is just, hey, please
look into this type stuff.
I am not optimistic on this issue at all.
If you are, let me know why.
Let me know why.
I should be more optimistic.
You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman